with picture and picture you can overlay
other apps well your user is doing
critical tasks such as watching a video
or navigating it's available whenever
your app is running on Oreo or above
let's dive in on how to add it to your
app a picture-in-picture overlay is a
mode that you enter from a visible
activity the user will see the contents
of the activity during the entire
transition animation so you'll want to
optimize this experience of course it
does count as a configuration change to
avoid visual hiccups make sure you
handle configuration changes in your
activity how do you design for pip
well designing for picture-in-picture or
pip is simple it's a small window so you
simply hide all of the views that aren't
relevant to the overlay for example if
you're playing a video you should only
show the video content and hide all of
the other views to create a simple
overlay another important thing to note
when designing for pip overlays have a
fixed aspect ratio you configure in code
this lets you specify the perfect aspect
ratio for your content now to support
user interaction with your pip overlay
you may supply a small number of
controls called remote actions you can
use remote actions for simple
interactions such as playing pausing a
video when in pip mode your activity
won't get any touch events instead you
configure remote actions with pending
intents when a user presses a remote
action the pending intent will be fired
and you'll be notified via a broadcast
receiver or other means when your user
expands the overlay back to a regular
activity you'll get notified via call
that you'll need to reshow all of your
hidden views when your activity exits
pip mode and there's one more detail to
note when an activity enters pip mode it
starts a new task without a back stack
when it exits pip mode it does not bring
back the original task so by default
back will leave your app your users
navigation history is lost to recover
your back stack check out our blog post
on recovering navigation state
picture-in-picture is a great way to
continue your users critical tasks as
they use their phone I've just covered
the essentials here to learn more check
out the blog posts and documentation on
picture-in-picture linked in the
description thanks for watching see you
next time
[Music]
you